bueno muchas gracias por la invitación
mire unos grandes sorpresas durante la
misa con trump fue la buena evaluación
curiosamente entre andrés manuel lópez
obrador y el presidente de trump
básicamente hubo un acuerdo implícito
que méxico coopera con estados undios en
materia de inmigración y eeuu no se mete
en méxico en temas de derechos humanos
corrupción y seguridad y otros temas y
esto obviamente va a dar un cambio
bailén tiene una agenda más amplia
cambio climático todos los temas y va a
requerir tiempo para reacomodar
reajustar relación entre eeuu y américa
y méxico pero al final se va a arreglar
porque hay tanto un juego para ambos
países ahora en cuanto al pandemia yo
creo que los procesadores tienen toda la
razón
yo creo que
hay una esencia una falta de cooperación
y por supuesto durante trump pero hasta
ahora con baile
en el tema de la pandemia de asesorar
ayudar acompañar los países de américa
latina y méxico
enfrentar esa crisis es tan tan terrible
entonces yo creo que presente barrio lo
va a hacer y fue un pedido a andrés
manuel lópez obrador y creo que se van a
se va a responder en un momento en este
momento obviamente la prioridad urgente
es arreglar este tema dentro de eeuu
pero yo creo que yo creo que pronto se
pasará a comparar con otros países de la
región incluyendo méxico bueno
justamente y le pregunto muy rápidamente
que vamos a poder esperar acerca del
futuro de la inmigración uno de los
temas más espinosos entre ambas naciones
bueno ese es un tema muy complicado en
este momento presidente de baile
necesita el apoyo colaboración de andrés
manuel lópez obrador porque hay una una
crisis en la administración ha tomado un
desafío pero yo lo llamaría una crisis
en la frontera con méxico eeuu y
básicamente hay grandes flujos que están
llegando muchos niños que no están con
sus padres y entonces
méxico es muy clave para la política de
presente padre migratorio en este
momento para reducir la gravedad de la
crisis de la frontera entonces yo creo
que va a ser muy muy importante la
cooperación porque si no se vuelve un
tema muy complicado políticamente para
la administración vayan que apenas está
empezando
gracias por su análisis